in the outskirts of tokyo stands
hakimitsu private academy a reputable
all-girls boarding school for
intelligent and well-mannered young
women but as the new school year rolls
around one tradition is going out the
window for the first time in the
school's long history boys are being
allowed to enroll it is now the first
day of the new school year but only five
boys are admitted to the school these
are our main protagonists kyoshi the
nerd gakuto the giant andre the hoodie
boy joe and the blonde shingo the boys
meet for the first time and are ecstatic
to be in the school as they are
surrounded by many attractive girls
however they soon notice that all the
female students intentionally ignore
them the boys are greatly troubled by
this but don't think too much of it and
decide to go on with their day a few
moments later they all head to their
respective classes during the lesson
kiyoshi drops his sumo wrestling eraser
and a girl named chio sees it much to
his embarrassment on seeing it chio
reveals that she is also a sumo fan and
starts a conversation with him after
school she invites kiyoshi to watch a
sumo match next week and he happily
accepts her offer later that evening
kiyoshi returns to his dorm room there
the other boys tell him about their plan
to peek into the girl's bathroom using a
two-way video system the pervy students
intend to dangle one cell phone over the
bathroom window to peek at the showering
girls kiyoshi is initially repulsed by
the idea especially because cheo will
also be there but the boys say it's far
too early in the plot to be simping and
they eventually coerce them into joining
them that night they head to the
school's roof and immediately implement
their plan however it doesn't take long
before things take a bad turn as kiyoshi
lowers the phone into the girl's
bathroom his friends advise him to be
careful noting that the attached phone
is his the news stuns kiyoshi causing
him to release his grip as the phone
falls into the girl's bathroom the boys
panic and fear and immediately sent
kyoshi to the bathroom to retrieve the
phone luckily he sees it in the changing
area and is relieved to find nobody
there but a few seconds later chio
unexpectedly enters the dressing room
kiyoshi is taken aback when he spots her
and immediately panics thinking he's
been caught however to his surprise chio
who isn't wearing her contacts mistakes
kiyoshi for a girl and drags him into
the bathroom there chio discovers why
most of the girls aren't talking to the
guys it turns out that a student
association known as the underground
school council or the usc had passed a
law for bidding girls to interact with
the five boys although the new chairman
has allowed male students to enroll the
usc doesn't like the new decision and
intends to keep things as they have
always been meanwhile back on the roof
the vice president of the usc maiko and
the secretary hannah discover the four
pervy boys and realize what they are up
to the duo strips the boys and ties them
up in the assembly hall for the entire
school to see the usc says that the
girls can't talk to the boys but they
didn't say anything about looking at
their pee-pees kiyoshi gets wind of this
and leaves the bathroom as he hides
outside the hall waiting for his peers
to get punished a few minutes later mary
the president of the council finds and
drags him to the stage to join the rest
of the boys the next morning the case is
reported and the boys are duly punished
for their crimes for their delinquent
behavior they receive an ultimatum from
the usc to stay one month in the school
prison or be expelled left with no
better alternative they accept
imprisonment on the first day of their
sentence they are warned against
escaping from the prison as that would
add an extra month to their sentence
furthermore they will be permanently
expelled if they attempt three or more
prison breaks the boys are petrified to
hear this and make a mental note to
never escape from their cell in the
following weeks the boys live in subpar
conditions they are tasked with hard
labor in prison and their punishment is
overseen by maiko alongside the rest of
the council executives the next day
while working kyoshi spots chio leaning
on a class window he seizes the
opportunity and talks to her as he
apologizes for his bad behavior chio is
pleased to hear his apology and accepts
it later that day she once again invites
him to watch a sumo tournament and shows
him a book containing details of the
time and location of the event hiyoshi
accepts her invitation which delights
chio as she enthusiastically bids him
goodbye when she leaves kiyoshi
immediately realizes that he is in a
dilemma as they are not given any free
time in prison despite this he plans to
go regardless of the cost and
brainstorms feasible plans to
successfully conduct a prison break he
eventually settles on one and decides to
make a hole in the school wall as an
escape route kiyoshi begins digging a
hole in the wall and tries his best to
be discreet however despite his best
efforts the nerdy gakuto finds out about
his plan kyoshi assumes that gakuto
would snitch on him and instantly begins
to panic but on the contrary gakuto
eases his fears and reveals that he will
aid his escape plan the nerd explains
that the day of kyoshi's rendezvous with
chio is also a special date for him as a
rare comic convention is scheduled to be
held that sounds way better than sumo
hence in return for his help gakuto
coerces kiyoshi to buy him a limited
edition figurine set from the convention
kyoshi agrees to his request prompting
gakuto to offer a more strategic plan
the nerd suggests that kyoshi escape on
the scheduled day by dressing up as a
girl and walking through the front gate
kiyoshi buys the idea and the duo
craftily steals a girl's uniform from
the school's laundry vehicle next gakuto
intentionally provokes mako and gets her
to cut his hair as punishment using his
severed hair he makes a ponytail wig for
kiyoshi to aid his disguise finally they
also get an mp3 sound of a person
farting he uses a cover when he leaves
the prison eventually the day of the
breakout finally arrives kiyoshi enters
the toilet changes into the girl's
uniform and dawns the wig when he's done
he leaves the speaker with the pooping
sound on the toilet seat and exits the
school premises this guy's not exactly
ferris bueller but he'll do as he leaves
the school environment he returns to his
prison clothes and meets chio at their
designated venue to have a nice sumo
date as they enjoy each other's company
chio suggests they take a photo together
kyoshi agrees and the couple takes a
nice selfie chio likes it and innocently
sends it to her family's group chat
meanwhile back at the prison school
maiko notices kyoshi's absence and
inquires of his whereabouts frightened
gakuto covers for him explaining that he
is in the toilet maiko buys the lie for
a few minutes but eventually goes to the
toilet to see for herself there she
hears the farting sound coming from a
closed stall and initially believes that
kiyoshi is there however after some time
she loses patience as he has been in the
stall for hours and forcefully opens the
door gakuto is scared to see this and
concludes that they have been caught
however when the door opens kiyoshi is
surprisingly inside much to gakuto's
relief ultimately kiyoshi leaves the
stall as they all head outside if he was
actually in there for hours he's got
bigger problems right as they step out
of the toilet mary stops them it is then
revealed that she is chio's elder sister
hence she saw the picture of the couple
at the sumo tournament from her family's
group chat she shows them the photo
which prompts maiko to check kiyoshi's
bag inside she finds a girl's uniform
alongside gakuto's wig and shows mary
thus confirming that he indeed escaped
from the prison in light of this the
council announces that each of the boy's
sentences is extended by an additional
month the boys are all livid with kyoshi
for compounding their dilemma especially
shingo who aggressively punches him in
the face for the next few days the boys
shun kiyoshi and shingo soon takes
charge of the group despite their added
sentence maiko and mary are not
satisfied with the boy's punishment and
propose that they'd be expelled to
achieve this they secretly establish an
operation called dto to have all the
boys rusticated they plot to make the
boys complete three prison breaks which
would have them expelled according to
the school rules the next day michael
calls shingo to her office and offers
him a variety of tasty foods in exchange
she asks for valuable information about
the boys during her questioning shingo
reveals that the giant andre likes her
maiko is pleased with his cooperation
and rewards jingo with a free pass out
of the prison for a limited time however
she adds that he must be back before the
allocated period elapses or else it'll
count as a prison break shingo thanks
her for the kind offer and vows to
return on time the following morning
maiko stands outside the prison fence
and lures andre towards her the boys try
to hold him back but andre falls for her
trap and tears through the fence to
reach his crush sadly as soon as he
passes the fence hannah pops out and
accuses him of attempting a prison break
shortly after gakuto notices that the
wires were already cut beforehand and
instantly realizes that the girls
planned the entire ordeal elsewhere in
the city shingo enjoys his free pass on
a date with a girl named anzu suddenly
he spots some boys bullying another kid
which reminds him of how he bullied
kyoshi he immediately feels guilty and
confesses to anzu about how he's been
helping mako anzu is moved by his
confession and reveals that she was
indeed sent by the council to stall him
hearing this shingo realizes that
there's just five minutes left until his
free time elapses and instantly races to
the school sadly he misses the deadline
by seconds and his late arrival is
counted as yet another prison break thus
bringing their tally to a total of three
and consequently resulting in expulsion
the boys are then brought before the
school's chairman to answer for their
crimes a few moments later chio gets
word of their imminent expulsion and
barges into the chairman's office to
defend them she accuses the usc of
setting the boys up but mary denies it
citing that she has no proof to support
her claims due to the lack of evidence
the chairman agrees to expel the boys in
three days after he signs the necessary
paperwork the boys are downcast by the
declaration and ultimately return to
their prison cell there shingo reveals
his betrayal to the group and asks for
their forgiveness the boys quickly
reconcile with him and begin
brainstorming ideas to prove that they
were indeed set up right then shingo
recalls seeing an email in the usc
office with the codename dto which is
the same name the usc used for their
operation he infers that the email may
contain valuable information that could
suffice as evidence gakutel approves of
his idea and proposes a plan to break
into the usc office by stealing the key
from maiko the next day the boys lure
maiko into arm wrestling with them while
she battles kiyoshi gakuto knocks the
table down and uses the opportunity to
quietly steal her keys the boys
eventually reassemble the table and
michael continues wrestling them while
gakuto heads to her office to find the
mail there he discovers that the mail
has been deleted and begins downloading
an email restoration software to recover
it back at the cell maiko successfully
defeats all the boys and prepares to
leave she searches her jacket and
realizes that her keys are lost however
gakuto arrives just in time and hands
her the keys pretending they had fallen
to the floor thankfully the boys are
safe from michael and her jacked arms
but once she leaves gakuto reveals that
he only installed the software and
didn't have time to fully recover the
mail the boys are devastated to hear
this and cry themselves to sleep that
night however they do not lose hope and
remain determined to prove their
innocence and halt their expulsion the
next day during lunch kiyoshi gets a
message from chio hidden in his food
seeing this the boys realize that they
can get help from outside so gakuto
starts making a plan that utilizes this
advantage they send a message to cheo
asking her to wait outside the prison
entrance at 8pm however they soon
discover that they'd need to unlock the
door to let her in that day hannah takes
over guarding duties from maiko much to
kyoshi's delight it turns out that hana
likes kiyoshi and he comes up with a
ploy to use her emotions to his
advantage just before the agreed time
shio arrives at the prison's entrance
and waits to be let in meanwhile hana
takes kiyoshi to a room and kisses him
seizing the opportunity kiyoshi
successfully unlocks the prison door to
let shio in after the kiss hana returns
kiyoshi to the cell while chio sneaks in
when kiyoshi returns to the prison cell
he quietly informs gakuto that the first
phase was successful hearing this gakuto
and the hoodie boy joe instantly ask
permission to go to the toilet hana
allows them to go and ultimately locks
up the prison before retiring for the
night back in the usc office mary and
michael are suspicious that the boys are
up to something so they leave their
office to check in on them in their
prison cell however they are relieved to
find all the boys fast asleep mary
starts gloating in victory with the
guarantee that the boys will be expelled
tomorrow the next morning the boys are
finally taken to the chairman to be
expelled the chairman brings out the
expulsion papers as mary brags about
winning however kyoshi suddenly faces
her and smirks stating that she has lost
mary brushes his words off and assumes
he's pulling a last-minute bluff but
kyoshi remains unmoved right then maiko
notices that two of the boys are
covering their faces and senses that
something is amiss when she uncovers
them she discovers that gakuto is
actually joe in disguise while joe is in
fact a disguised chio the usc is taken
aback by the revelation and demands an
explanation finally kiyoshi shares what
really transpired last night apparently
after chio sneaked into the prison she
went straight to the toilet at the same
time gakuto and the hoodie boy joe who
were given a signal by kiyoshi asked
permission to go to the same toilet
there the trio exchanged clothes chio is
disguised as joe while joe is disguised
as gakuto when they were taken back to
the prison cell the real gakutel had all
night to look for an opportunity to
enter the usc office this opportunity
came when michael and mary went to check
the boy's prison cell he entered the usc
office and successfully retrieved the
deleted dto emails after kiyoshi's
revelation the real gakutel enters the
office he brings out a flash drive
containing the files and hands it to the
chairman using his computer the school
official accesses the drive and confirms
that the boy's accusations are indeed
true he sees all the things that the usc
had been doing to the boys including the
brutality and the setups hence he
retracts his declaration to expel them
and acquits them of all charges as they
have fully served their initial sentence
the boys are overjoyed by the news and
return to the normal school where they
join the rest of the students as the usc
is now defeated the boys can enjoy their
school lives with the girls kyoshi is
fed by chio in the cafeteria while the
rest of the boys are showered with
attention by the rest of the girls back
at the chairman's office the usc is
faced with the penalty of their actions
just like the boys the three usc members
are imprisoned and made to serve a
sentence the girls are paraded in front
of the entire school and eventually
enter their cell as kiyoshi fiercely
locks eyes with mary subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching